[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur tv 78 c'est l'heure du 7-8
journal l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en 26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de ce mercredi
12 septembre il n'est plus le maire de
coignières jean-pierre sevestre remis
hier sa démission au préfet des yvelines
à la tête de la commune depuis 2015
l'ex-édile n'avait plus de majorité au
sein de son conseil municipal
ses explications et les réactions des
élus quoi n'y a rien dans cette édition
alors que le service autolib c'est
arrêter les trottinettes électriques
débarque dans les yvelines une borne de
location est en service depuis cet été à
la gare de versailles rive gauche
à l'origine une petite start up du
département qui pourrait proposer le
service prochainement à saint quentin en
yvelines
et puis c'est ce samedi au vélodrome
nationale enceinte saint-quentinoise
organise le premier vélodrome ce porte
veille d'une journée d'activités
gratuites sur le thème notamment de la
glisse urbaine on détaille le programme
avec bruce golstein responsable
marketing et communication au vélodrome
nationale et puis autre invité de ce
journal le mort d'asia et georges
beliaev qui signe les bâtisseurs de
bonheur c'est un roman de science
fiction est mais aussi une fable
humaniste qui porte un regard sur
l'avenir visite internationale dans les
yvelines le prince héritier du japon
naruhito est au château de versailles ce
soit reçue par emmanuel macron dans le
cadre des 160 ans de relations
diplomatiques entre les deux pays
représentations de théâtre et dîner au
programme de la soirée
attention la circulation aux abords du
château sera compliqué
le prince naruhito qui était hier à
mardi à montigny le bretonneux dans les
locaux de l'institut franco japonais à
l'issue semblait inéluctable après
plusieurs mois de tension au conseil
municipal le maire de coignières rend
son écharpe et jean-pierre ce lait sera
remis hier sa démission dans une lettre
aux habitants ils étaient sérieusement
contesté au sein même de sa majorité
depuis l arrêt du processus de fusion
avec la commune voisine de maurepas un
projet qui avait rencontré auprès des
habitants mais aussi des aides
lui de nombreuses oppositions les
précisions et de mélanie poker une
décision qu'il qualifie de douloureuses
mais nécessaires
jean-pierre sevestre a présenté les
mains dion septembre sa démission préfet
des yvelines
il met fin à des mois de tensions au
sein du conseil municipal de coignières
pour moi c'est la meilleure solution
parce que je considère qu'il convient
maintenant de donner la parole aux
poignets rien pour leur permettre de
peut même de choisir l'avenir de leur
ville
sereinement après d'une préparation
d'élections peut-être qui intervient
dans plus tard et c'est une des pistes y
ont tout à fait personnelle et je
considère que pour le bienfait de mon
équipe ma démission je ne peux pas
appliqué mon équipe justement dans cette
démission c'est une démission une
démarche tout à fait personnel présent
au conseil municipal de la ville depuis
plus de 17 ans jean-pierre sevestre est
élu mais en avril 2015
elle les premières tensions apparaissent
au printemps vous mon du projet de
fusion avortée avec maurepas et se
cristallisent au mois de juin 2018
autour des choix de gestion de la ville
conseils municipaux ou le appels à la
démission elle pouvait pas en être
autrement c'était encore d'une situation
de blocage qui pourrait justifier à me
semble-t-il d'une manière tout à fait
objectif cette démission c'est que
monsieur cfa et perdu la confiance de la
population perde une partie de la
confiance de ces deux-là gens parce
qu'ils se sont sentis floués dans la
sphère de la fusion quand même il aurait
eu une peur et perdu une majorité dans
la majorité
sauf que je trouvais même la sortie peu
élégante que s'il égratigne un peu tout
le monde
on flatte en dessous ce qui voulait
virer enfin bon ok les cris au ton très
peu pour justifier quoi c'est une c'est
une bonne chose aujourd'hui que le maire
démissionne de toute façon je pense
qu'il était dans une situation quasi
impossible depuis plusieurs mois ne
pouvait plus continuer
je dirais à gouverner cette commune la
meilleure des choses aujourd'hui dans
l'intérêt de la commune et des poignées
rien ça serait une démission collective
et de nouvelles élections le préfet peut
très bien convoqué assez rapidement à
mon sens de nouvelles élections des
élections qui pourraient se dérouler
peut-être même avant la fin de l'année
en cas de scrutin ali bousselham et
didier fischer n'exclut pas d'être tête
de liste
l'intérim est aujourd'hui assurée par
dominique catelin première adjointe de
la commune
un conseil municipal est prévue le 19
septembre prochain
et précisons que pour que de nouvelles
élections se tiennent au moins un tiers
de la majorité du conseil municipal doit
démissionner sinon le choix du nouveau
maire se fera est directement par un
vote des conseillers municipaux quelques
réactions après cette démission
notamment celle du maire de maurepas
grégory gary astier avec qui jean pierre
serait ce travail mené notamment le
projet de fusion
dans un communiqué l'élu regrette ce
choix de par ses liens tissés avec
jean-pierre sevestre et aussi avec sa
commune de maurepas il salue un homme
passionné par sa ville et dévoué à
l'intérêt général et jean michel
fourgous ce mercredi à matignon le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et d'autres élus se sont rendus dans les
bureaux du premier ministre pour
défendre la ligne 18 est la première
tranche de ce super métro n'arrivera pas
elle n'arrivera pas en 2024 comme
annoncé initialement mais à l'horizon
2027 sur le plateau de saclay seulement
en 2030 à saint quentin en yvelines
la délégation d'élus a profité du rendez
vous pour donner des solutions et des
arguments afin de tenir les délais
initiaux de la ligne 18 retardé sa mise
en oeuvre compromettrait la réussite du
projet paris saclay affirme saint
quentin en yvelines dans un communiqué
après le vélib et les voitures
électriques c'est au tour de la
trottinette électrique de faire son
entrée dans la vie des yvelinois une
bande de location est en service depuis
le mois d'août à versailles et c'est une
petite start up du département qui est à
l'origine de ce projet ses fondateurs
compte bien étendre le service dans le
reste du département
reportage d'isabelle carré izco
impossible de la manquer en sortant de
la gare de versailles rive gauche
cette station de location de
trottinettes et la première et unique du
département à l'origine de ce projet
deux yvelinois qui ont parié sur ce
service pratique et écolo le principe
est simple vous avez téléchargé
l'application android je me mets
libération trottinette je choisis
ensuite en parallèle vous avez un casier
qui s'est ouvert sur le côté dans lequel
je pouvoir retirer un casque et un
cadenas qui sont dans un petit sac et je
pars shao ning ce sont en fait de
mobilité complémentaires qui vient
s'additionner aux transports publics
existent ou transport privé qui vit qui
n'est pas concurrent du vélo puisque
chacun choisit son mode de transport
mais il contribue effectivement à
fluidifier la circulation et améliorer
les choses
l'ambition de cette start up qui cultive
son identité yvelinoise c'est de
s'implanter dans tout le département
nous sommes une société complètement
yvelinoise on dit voilà puisque notre
siège est à versailles et on espère
d'ailleurs que toutes les collectivités
vont nous aider dans cette démarche là à
saint quentin en yvelines dans un
premier temps on aura sûrement 2 points
2 essais de tests c'est à dire qu'on
fera un premier test de la gare de
saint-quentin justement une zone
d'activité qui sera peut-être celle du
parc ariane et la deuxième demande de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est
d'étudier justement la zone en fait de
plaisir les clayes-sous-bois avec toute
la nouvelle zone commerciale qui existe
les deux fondateurs qui ont parié toutes
leurs économies dans ce projet misent
sur une centaine de stations d'ici un an
mercredi jour de sortie au cinéma c'est
le jour aussi que nous avons choisi pour
aller faire le tour des salles
saint-quentinoise d'érection ce soir
l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois le coup de coeur du
moment à l'affiché du cinéma
c'est au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude retrouvés à l'espace philippe
noiret cette semaine le dernier film de
spike lee dont je ne me risquerai pas à
prononcer le titre que vous allez voir
sur l'écran donc se paye qu'il revient
en force et en verve avec son dernier
film et il a électrisé la croisette
cette année puisqu'il a obtenu le grand
prix du jury il s'inspire d'une histoire
vraie une histoire incroyable d'un
policier afro américain qui s'est
infiltré dans le klu klux klan donc
voilà c'est un mélange réjouissons de
comédie policière de satire sociale de
pamphlets parce que c'est une charge
aussi très ouverte contre l'amérique de
trump contre l'actuel président
américain voilà en résumé un film
d'action militante pour ne pas bouder
notre plaisir à retrouver dans notre
salle à l'espace philippe noiret cette
semaine beaucoup cox hausse
[Musique]
j'accueille sur ce plateau mon premier
invité george abela f bonsoir vous êtes
l'auteur de ce livre les bâtisseurs de
bonheur c'est une auto édition publiée
sur amazon cette année en 2018 tout
récemment alors c'est un roman à double
lecture un roman de science fiction mais
c'est aussi une fable humaniste pour
parler du monde de demain imaginer le
monde de demain on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler
précisons aussi que ce livre est en lice
dans le concours qui et les plumes
francophones sur un concours lancé
notamment par amazon on en dire un mot
juste après déjà pourquoi écrire ce
roman
pourquoi vous vous lancer dans
l'écriture de ce premier roman est
pourquoi le publier alors il ya une
double motivation pour pour l'écriture
de ce roman
la première c'était de ça fait longtemps
que je travaillais sur différents
projets et notamment des projets dans
sorte de l'amélioration de la de la
société on va dire si c'était des
projets j'avais j'avais dans la tête
et puis l'élément déclencheur ça a été
le jour où à vous je suis tombé sur le
concours amazon enfin ces amazones et
tv5monde
en réalité et le jour je suis tombé sur
ce sur ce concours j'ai décidé de
relever le défi est donc de finaliser ce
projet d'écriture
il y avait déjà des boucs était avancé
et puis et puis là donc j'en ai fait un
ouvrage que vous avez entre les mains on
le disait c'est un roman avec une double
lecture on parlera tout à l'heure du
contenu lui a résumé qui avec un roman
de science fiction se placera dans
l'année 2030
c'est aussi une fable voilà pour
imaginer le monde de demain pourquoi
proposer ce
ces solutions parce que vous imaginez
aussi des solutions pour le monde de
demain les les proposer aux lecteurs
alors déjà c'est un ouvrage comme vous
dites de science fiction donc science
fiction au sens d'anticipation c'est à
dire qu'est ce qui va se passer demain
c'est pas c'est pas une dystopie comme
on a peut-être l'habitude de les voir
c'est à dire qu'on arrive dans un monde
déjà tous fabriqués et en fait moi j'ai
développé toute la partie transition il
faut dire qu'on part de la société
actuelle et on arrive dans une nouvelle
société donc suite à un incident en fin
ou insiste mme ça dépend comme on le
considère sur la planète qui est une
crise économique et crise économique on
connaît on en a déjà vécu n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça en 2008 on a mis à peu
près dix ans pour sortir de la crise
économique et on sent que les prémisses
peut-être d'une prochaine centre inde
on le voit arriver et donc l'idée de ce
roman c'est de dire mais finalement
comment on pourrait contrecarrer
l'arrivée de cette crise économique et
faire en sorte que les effets soient
moindres voir qui est pas d'effet du
tout et ces solutions vous exploser ce
qu'elles sont réalisables là on est dans
un roman de science fiction est ce que
dans notre monde le monde réel c'est
tout à fait réalisable ce dimanche alors
justement j'ai pris j'ai privilégié le
côté réaliste au sens ce projet c'est à
dire c'est pas ça utopiste au sens où on
pourrait l'entendre et donc moi dans la
dans la vie je suis chef de projet donc
j'ai l'habitude d'emmener des projets je
fais beaucoup de créations enfin les
créations de enfin deux concepts ou de
projets et donc du coup je me suis je me
suis un peu basé là dessus pour imaginer
une direction différente on peut dire
que c'est un une oeuvre militante dans
un certain brio sorte en quelque sorte
oui et donc après vous me posez la
question pourquoi dans l'espace parce
que déjà je suis ça se passe dans
l'espace
effectivement pas au début non au début
ça se passe sur mer le personnage
principal on va le présenter dans un
instant est envoyé dans l'espace qui et
pour quoi alors d'abord il va te faire
de ces projets là sur la terre est en
fait la stratégie qu'avait été qui
avaient été mises en place qu'on va
découvrir ou dans le livre c'est non
seulement d'arranger les choses sur
terre mais en même temps de propager la
civilisation dans l'espace et donc
d'abord dans un premier temps ils vont
aller sur la lune pour aller prendre
possession de la lune d exploiter ces
matières premières et après il ya un
autre projet qui va être montée qui va
être plus ambitieux qui va en gros
comment dire propager notre une autre
culture et cette civilisation
l'ajustement dans l'espace qu'on plante
le décor de ce livre on vous l'a dit on
est en février 2030
il ya une grande crise économique qui
qui s'abat alors la france pour faire
face mais met en place un projet le nom
de ce livre c'est les bâtisseurs de
bonheur c'est le nom du projet avec le
met en place la france c'est le nom
qu'ils vont se donner en fait bon se
donnait
et françois cervantes qui est le
personnage principal de ce roman va
prendre part directement dans cette
aventure
oui parce que tu as vu ce que prendrait
pas françois cervantès c'est un garçon
qui est un peu enfin cas pas été épargné
par la vie et qui est journaliste façon
d'ambition c'est à devenir journaliste
et donc il va il va arriver au contact
de d'un certain nombre de choses et de
personnes
enfin de par son métier de journaliste
que vous devez bien connaître et la
crise économique éclate et donc là il
est il fait partie des gens fin sur la
base du volontariat mais les fais partie
des gens à qui on va donner la mission
de réinventer une nouvelle société
c'est à dire faisant en sorte que les
choses qui n'ont pas marché dans notre
société actuelle marche dans cette
modélisation et donc il va traverser les
fait partie des justement des bâtisseurs
est à dire des gens qui vont faire la
promotion de faire la promotion est
monté ce projet là jusqu'au moment où il
arrivera c'est quelqu'un qui est un
petit peu là je dire la bougeotte phase
doit lire qu il a fait c'est un projet
qui marche bien et c est donc il part
sur autre chose et c'est à ce moment là
qu'il va partir on en parlait tout à
l'heure au téléphone est ce que c'est un
rêveur ce françois cervantès cervantes
ça peut faire penser à al auteur de don
quichotte on sait que don quichotte est
un utopiste un rêveur est ce qu'on peut
le qualifier de rêveurs ou au contraire
c'est quelqu'un qui agit c'est pas un
rêveur c'est un pragmatique c'est à dire
que il prend les choses
il regarde les choses comme elles disent
comme arrive devant lui il les analyse
il prend un certain nombre de décisions
alors c'est pas lui qui prend la
décision seul puisque la construction de
cet ouvrage en fait c'est basé sur
l'intelligence collective d'accord donc
on se met ensemble autour de la table on
prend des décisions et ces décisions
vont amener dans une certaine direction
et donc lui il se retrouve un peu
je veux dire par hasard non parce que
rien n'est jamais dû au hasard mais sur
le principe
donc je les mécanismes que j'ai mis en
place qui sont notamment les mécanismes
de détection sans candidat il se
retrouve à la tête de son groupe fait
partie du comité de gouvernance et donc
c'est lui qui va faire partie des gens
qui vont emmener projet dans une
certaine direction
la suite est bien sûr à découvrir dans
cet ouvrage dernière question ce qui
nous reste très peu de temps on l'a dit
il est en lice pour le concours des plus
francophone stains un concours lancé par
amazon et et tv5 monde pourquoi ils
participent et qu'est ce que ça pourrait
vous apporter
alors déjà je vous disais en début
d'interview que c'est un j'ai relevé le
défi afin de concourir parce que c'est
quand même pas une mince aventure que
pour un premier roman
moi j'avais jamais toucher à ça donc
sortir un livre de 470 pages bon ça ça
m'a occupé quand même un petit peu
donc il y avait ce côté challenge
justement que mon françois cervantès
c'est à dire des jusqu'au boutistes
gérer le ski masse qui m'a interpellé
c'est que le concours cette année est
parrainée par bernard werber qui est un
écrivain bien connu qui aussi à traiter
des sujets fally fait un peu des sujets
en rupture je dirais par rapport à par
rapport à la le monde dans lequel on vit
voilà et du coup j'ai décidé de relever
ce challenge et on peut le retrouver
cet ouvrage qui est publié sur amazon
les bâtisseurs de bonheur et c'est écrit
par vous je le rappelle georges beliaev
merci d'avoir été avec nous dans cette
émission
merci à vous un mot de sport avec un
club basé dans le département et pas
n'importe lequel le paris saint germain
a présenté récemment son futur centre
d'entraînement
un équipement ultramoderne qui verra le
jour à poissy 17 terrains de football et
un stade de 5000 places les contours de
ce projet d'envergure avec michael et
demi d'euros le futur centre
d'entraînement du psg se dévoile ce
vendredi 7 septembre à poissy la
direction parisienne a présenté les
contours du site de 74 hectares qui sera
implanté sur la commune à 25 minutes du
parc des princes 1 on y retrouvera
notamment 17 terrains de football un
dojo et un terrain de handball la
recherche du paris saint germain
aujourd'hui c'est de recréer ali
avec l'ensemble de ses activités
sportives aujourd'hui nous sommes est
allé sur le territoire parce que ya une
histoire qui s'inscrit de cette manière
là donc on rit c'est ta première fois
que le toutes les activités sportives du
paris saint germain on voir s'implanter
sur un même lieu
la livraison programmée à l'été 2000 21
prévoit également l'implantation d'un
stade de football de 5000 places il y
aura les féminines il y aura l'équipe
réserve
les professionnels vont pouvoir
l'utiliser également de temps en temps
il y aura l'association et d'autres
peut-être gens du territoire qui
pourront occuper et utiliser ce stade le
début des travaux est programmé pour
l'été 2010 9 coût total de l'opération
plus de 220 millions d'euros entièrement
financés par le psg
le prix du transfert du brésilien neymar
dans le club de la capitale un nouvel
invité avec moi sur ce plateau bruce
goldstein bonsoir vous êtes un
responsable marketing et communication
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le vélodrome
qui organise ce week-end le vélodrome
aux forces day c'est une journée dédiée
aux activités sportives vous pourrez
notamment découvrir les sports de glisse
urbaine et on le dira tout à l'heure
c'est des activités qui sont totalement
gratuites avant de présenter le
programme de la journée
bruce et le premier on peut dire grand
événement depuis la finale de la coupe
du monde 2018 une victoire de la france
le vélodrome avait fait le plein pour
cet événement c'était un grand moment
peut le dire du dans l'histoire du
vélodrome la jeune histoire du vélodrome
national très grand moment oui
effectivement accueilli un peu plus de
6000 spectateurs l'occasion de cette
finale de coupe du monde avec la cerise
sur le gâteau le deuxième coupe du monde
donc oui effectivement on essaye de
surfer sur le succès de cette opération
là on organisant cette fois ci une
programmation d'activités sportives
accessibles au plus grand nombre et de
manière plus participative cette fois ci
on sera moins devant la télé ce coup ci
pourquoi organiser ce vélodrome sport
day vous l'aï dit c'est s'adresser à un
grand public à tout public
exactement en fait on va y greffer une
nouvelle thématique donc les sports de
glisse urbaine d'accord
ça vient vraiment en complément de ce
qu'on a proposé jusqu'à présent donc on
va accueillir des activités type
overboard avec des circuits qu'on va
mettre en place ces dames de football un
des trampolines on va voir au ciné mur
d'escaladé mobile vraiment se
diversifier au niveau de notre panel
d'activités sportives mais dix nouvelles
thématiques sur la glisse urbaine qu'est
ce qui était proposé alors on connaît le
vélodrome pour ceux qui regardent
régulièrement tv 78 qu'est ce qui a été
proposé jusqu'à présent qui était-il
possible de faire et qui est il possible
de faire sur place au vélo en national
au jour d'aujourd'hui oui aujourd'hui
basse on a toujours les mêmes scores
depuis l'inauguration en albane minton
en libre accès évidemment donc ça ça
fait partie de notre catégorie multi
sports on a évident le cyclisme sur
piste accessible au plus grand nombre
mais on a les athlètes de l'équipe de
france au quotidien sur cette piste mais
ce qui fait notre particularité c'est
qu'on loue vraiment au plus grand nombre
avec la volonté de démocratiser cette
pratique là et évidemment le bmx à
l'extérieur avec le fameux stadium
couvert ni d'ailleurs le précise la
fédération française de cyclisme et est
directement implanté sur ce site du
vélodrome quelle activité on va pouvoir
découvrir sur place dont on est un petit
peu parlé quel sera le programme de
cette journée du vélodrome ce
portefeuille on va faut venir pour le
découvrir c'est le meilleur moyen mais
effectivement d'un programme très
complet qui va démarrer à partir de 10
heures sur le site est affichée en tout
cas exactement et jusqu'à 18 heures et
vous allez avoir justement alors
évidemment tout ce qu'on a proposé
jusqu'à présent mais comme je vais en
introduit des nouvelles pratiques autour
de la glisse urbaine donc les parcours
overboard trampoline donc là on est
moins dans la glisse mais ça qu'on a
voulu vraiment proposer une
programmation multi-activités donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle on a mis en
place ces nouvelles pratiques avec pour
objectif à terme de dévoiler notre
nouvelle école de sport d'accord donc
c'est pour aussi cette raison là qu'on
me propose de nouveaux sports savoir
quelles vont être les intérêts de la
population locale leurs attentes
et puis ensuite proposé au sein d'une
future école de sport qui s'implanterait
au vélodrome donc ça c'est un projet
pour le futur pour lever le rhône qui va
bientôt arriver je vous dévoile un petit
scoop c'est très bien
juste on le disait tout à l'heure qu'on
soit un enfant âgé de 4 ans et un adulte
on peut venir ça s'adresse vraiment à
tout le monde c'est exactement pour les
familles les enfants accompagnés
évidemment les adolescents et les
adultes aussi
c'est vraiment ouvert aux plus grands
noms ça montre aussi la vocation du
vélodrome à accueillir ce genre
d'événement des événements sportifs
aussi des grands événements à deux
compétitions comme les championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste
le vélodrome c'est du sport mais mais
pas que on essaye au vélodrome de
proposer une programmation large part se
diversifie donc la partie événement
participatif avec sa valeur au mosport
de ce day accessible au plus grand
nombre comme je l'aï dit je le répète et
après on a vraiment une programmation
d'événements sportifs et culturels
alors vélo avec la fédération française
de cyclisme mais également hors vélo
avec notamment cette année la
possibilité d'accueillir en mai 2019 les
champagnes france de gymnastique
d'accord avec l'association j'aime qui
est implanté également à guyancourt
on aura aussi dont classe en pourparlers
avec la mairie de montigny le bretonneux
mais on pourrait éventuellement
accueillir un festival électro sur le
même modèle que celui qu'on a
réceptionné l'année dernière avec un
fort succès plus de 6000 personnes
également donc voilà pas mal de projets
sur le grill comme on dit qui devrait
aboutir
et ça tout ça c'est à suivre en tout cas
sur le site du vélodrome nationale qui
va peut-être s'afficher ça y est il
s'affiche en bas de l'écran on peut
également réserver pour venir à cette
journée de ski et ces surréservations et
on précise que ce vélodrome spurs est
cette grande journée d'activités
sportives sera gratuite merci à à
bruxelles golstein d'avoir à vous un tel
que vous êtes le responsable marketing
et communication au vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines pour
terminer encore du sport justement au
coeur d'une nouvelle exposition au musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
avec la ryder cup et les jeux olympiques
de 2024 la thématique était tout trouvé
le sport dans la vie comme à la ville
c'est jusqu'au mois de mars découverte
de cette exposition avec marylène yapi
chinois
[Musique]
tout comme il est entré dans nos salons
via la télévision le sport s'invite au
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines
les équipes ont travaillé sur l'histoire
de l'agglomération et de sa relation
avec le sport c'est une exposition du
cou qui retrace l'histoire du sport sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines et dans la vie de ses habitants
c'est pour cela qu'elle s'appelle dans
la vie comme à la ville elle se divise
en trois parties une partie qui
s'appelle la ville en sport qui retrace
du coup le développement du sport sur le
territoire des premiers stades qui était
deschamps prêté par la sncf au grand
stade qu'on peut connaître maintenant
ensuite on arrive dans une deuxième
partie qui s'appelle spectaculairement
sport qui retrace du coup l'histoire de
deux équipements phares du territoire
qui sont le golf national elle vélodrome
nationale qui nous ont permis d'avoir de
nombreux prêts afin d'exposer du coup un
vélo et différents équipements utilisés
par les sportifs établir son régime
alimentaire découvrir le mode sportswear
au fil des années et révéler son profil
sportif
la troisième partie le sport au
quotidien et plus interactive et
l'aveyron en fait seul au sommet ça nous
propose un sport et scénographe nicolas
franches aux et stéphane guillon on
souhaitait une installation moderne des
logiciels informatiques ont été
spécialement développés comme la sq
heitz portman c'est une carte en fait
qui présente on va dire comme un élément
complémentaire à l'exposition où on peut
retrouver les différents équipements du
territoire l'exposition sport à la vie
comme à la ville est ouverte au public
jusqu'au 9 mars 2019
c'est la fin du set 8 journal cette
édition et l'ensemble de ces reportages
sont à consulter sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]